are you married right now
no no but i was with simon we were
married for like eight years yeah and
broke up for like three years and then
got back together again so we've been
you know together basically for 21 years
but you're together with him now
uh-huh oh wow what was those three years
like when you guys broke madness i was
kidding no
oh someone oh
congresswoman
oh congress
um no i mean i think i think that's why
i say
nothing is written so nothing is forever
um because if somebody does work on
themselves and those issues that you're
talking about and obviously he is you
know it always could come back together
again it could you know if both parties
are in the same place
three years from now right did you see
anybody else in those three years
what do you think
yeah
you asked it
you embarrassed was it fun how dare you
ask me a question if those three i know
this three years fun i have fun no
matter where i am uh-huh what i'm doing
yeah yeah i'm a fun-loving person yeah
yeah wow
[Laughter]
next question
are you you're i don't know are you
filipino yeah filipino spanish chinese
born and raised in hawaii wow
is your mom filipino who's my dad's from
philippines my mom's from hawaii but
they're both filipino spanish and on my
dad's side got some chinese so your dad
did live in the philippine group yeah he
moved to hawaii when he was like 18 i
think 17 18. yeah what island was he
from uh from occidental
mindoro that's right oh wow
what is that that sounds like a [ __ ]
medication
babe i'm visayan i'm from cebu
yeah
yeah he's been there i love it i want to
go to cebu i've always wanted to go
there we're going back in september but
you are and you're broken up yeah
[Music]
yeah thank you well i mean but here's
the deal it's like it's business we we
have a
you
oh [ __ ] you dear career go [ __ ] yourself
all right i'll take a [ __ ] minute and
i'll raise you to the tip of the tree
that's an exponential
sassy
yeah so we we have probably 40 years in
this business [ __ ]
yeah yeah i'll learn you a few things i
know you do well sorry
i get nervous i get nervous i don't know
what the [ __ ] to say yes
but um no we we're bowed down we're
shooting a show in the philippines we
have a project that we're going to do a
pilot it's a business like you said it's
business it's business and um but you
know if we ever get this picked up
she'd be a great job i think she would
yeah
very judgmental that way yeah yeah yeah
um when how did you get with the easter
sunday did you you probably didn't have
the audition right i auditioned for the
mom role
i wanted to play the mom but uh you know
because she's
lydia's petite he wanted her to be a
tiny tyrant i mean it says that in the
in the you know the breakdown so um
physically
i'm not it and uh i i did play
his
mom and his